earlier we got a little bit of a taste
of two musicals now in Las Vegas it's
called Musical and a musical about Star
Wars so now we're going to get a sneak
peek of musical uh and Tom the directors
he's going to set the scene for us
playing actress Jennifer Coolidge from
you know Legally Blonde and all that fun
stuff and Kurt star of White Lotus give
it up for actress Carly sakalov take it
away guys
okay so as we said musical does current
events and news but sometimes the news
is bad so how do you make it funny
inflation sluggish economy even the best
celebrities in the world need second
jobs Bernie Sanders is a Walmart greeter
Celine Dion is now singing at bar
mitzvahs even Emmy Award winner Jennifer
Coolidge is now the voice of your Google
Navigation
take it
okay let's go
if you follow this route you'll reach
your destination in 19 minutes but hey
pull up over here will ya it's
Allegiance Stadium
Sports
makes me want a hot dog real bad
oh you missed it
recalculating okay there's an eight
minute slowdown in Las Vegas Boulevard
but that's okay because we're coming up
on the Venetian
oh God I always wanna go on one of those
Gondola rides with a guy and the pole
yeah as long as he doesn't throw me out
of the boat
oh you missed it recalculating
uh oh there's a speed cam up ahead slow
down and say cheese
hmm cheese
we're calculating
oh my goodness thank you very much I
love that the new voice of ways eh that
was truly incredible Carly thank you wow
wow wow if you want to watch more a
musical about Star Wars or musical runs
Thursdays through Sundays at the V
theater that's inside Miracle Mile at
Planet Hollywood you know that area it
begins at 4 30. you're never gonna hear
the word recalculating another another
way ever again if you want to see
musical the musical runs Tuesdays
through Sundays at six o'clock the show
is recommended for those 12 and older
also at the V theater tickets start at
80 for both shows vtheater.com